we found this video of Milton Friedman
Milton Friedman who of course is the
famed libertarian Economist who once by
the way was on the front page of the New
York Times with me picture of him he has
already passed away it was a picture of
him me Jordan Peterson Ben Shapiro I
think Stephen Crowder was on there a
couple other people as the leaders of
the alt-right that was the front page of
the New York Times anyway he was just an
economist a Libertarian Economist he
liked small government he liked low
taxes he didn't like government
interference in people's relationships
with each other and all those things
well he went on Phil Donahue's show this
has got to be early 80s and basically
laid out a beautiful case for for
exactly what we should be fighting for
right now freedom and for democracy and
our ability to exchange goods and ideas
with other people without government
interference it's just so beautiful just
take a look when you when you see the
greed and the concentration of Power
with it aren't you ever did you ever
have a moment of doubt about capitalism
and whether greed's a good idea to run
on well first of all tell me is there
some Society you know that doesn't run
on Greed you think Russia doesn't run on
Greed you think China doesn't run on
great what is greed
of course none of us are greedy it's
only the other fellow who's created
this the world runs
on individuals pursuing their separate
interests the great achievements
of civilization have not come from
government bureaus Einstein didn't
construct his theory under order from a
from a bureaucrat
Henry Ford didn't revolutionize the
automobile industry that way but it
seems to reward not virtue as much as
ability to manipulate the system and
what does reward virtue you think the
Communist commissary Awards virtue
you think a Hitler rewards virtue
you think excuse me if you'll pardon me
do you think American president's reward
virtue
do they choose their appointees on the
basis of the virtue of the people
appointed or on the basis of their
political clout
is it really true that political
self-interest is nobler somehow than
economic self-enters
you know I think you're taking a lot of
things for granted just tell me where in
the world you find these angels
who are going to organize Society for us
well I don't even trust you to do that
isn't that beautiful and I happen to I
liked Phil Donahue my mom used to always
watch Donahue when I was at school I'd
come home and I think Donahue was on at
four o'clock I would watch Donahue with
my mom he was he was a perfectly fine
host but it's nice when you see someone
sort of put in their place and Milton
Friedman again all he was was basically
a Libertarian Economist who liked free
markets and governments out of the way
um but this reflexive argument of
somehow capitalism and our ability to be
free and make decisions for ourselves
he's so deeply connected to Greed I
believe there was a Gordon gecko guy who
once said that greed is good that we
should all go out there and do what is
best for ourselves and if you do that
within the idea that when you do what's
best for you you start doing what's best
for your family and your community you
don't destroy everything around you are
there going to be bad actors within that
are there going to be genuinely greedy
people who will act unethically and all
those things yes but if you think that
just giving the government the power to
tell you what to do is somehow going to
be better than you doing it for yourself
well then I think you should probably
watch a little more Milton Friedman or
read a book by another alt-right Maniac
Thomas soul that might be good too